from alzer's Heidi Joe Castro in
Washington DC so Heidi not a huge
surprise this given how he was polling
what else did uh chrisy have to say and
and how is this likely to uh affect the
race with less than a week to go now
till that Iowa
caucus yeah Chris Christie he had
positioned himself in a unique place in
this GOP field as the obvious anti-trump
candidate and he was the only one to
unequivocally condemn the former
president out of that field but it was a
message that was risky and did not
resonate with goop voters and so because
he barely even showed up on these polls
uh chrisy announced today in New
Hampshire before a group of supporters
that he was suspending the race but he
did so in a fiery speech which he used
to really get in that final word against
Trump saying that he's known Trump for
more than 20 years in fact Christie was
Trump's advisor during the
2016 campaign and chrisy said he would
never again play a role in enabling
Trump to return to become president
again and he said that he promised his
voters that if Trump were to become
president again he would always put his
own selfish interests above the
interests of his country what's notable
here is that in this speech Christie did
not endorse any of the remaining
candidates not Nikki Haley nor Ronda
Sanz and in fact in a hot microphone
moment just before the speech he was
caught disparaging them saying that
Haley didn't stand a chance in that
DeSantis was quote petrified now those
two are the only viable contenders left
standing uh confronting Trump but yeah
that's right the polls show that they're
at least trailing by more than 30 points
behind Trump the clear front runner but
they two will be facing off against each
other in a debate in Iowa tonight even
As Trump will host his own solo town
hall on Fox news also at the same time
all of this leading up to the first
votes to be cast in the Republican
primary which will be in Iowa on Monday
hasm yep should be interested to see how
this pans out over the next few days
Heidi Joe Castro live for us there in
Washington